[Music]
oh
[ __ ] boy is this a [ __ ] jojo's
reference
yes if you've hung around this community
for any extended period of time or
sometimes even if you haven't you would
have definitely come across
someone or something that would have
exposed you to the weird and wonderful
world of jojo's bizarre adventure
it's bold it's brash and 20 outside it
probably makes absolutely no [ __ ]
sense but for whatever reason jojo seems
to have become one of the most loved
franchise in this modern anime era and
if you're an active part of this anime
community there is no
running away from it it's rare to see a
franchise so unanimously shouted in love
with such a wide cultural reach in our
community
fueled by a fan base so eager and
passionate to share it which begs the
question
why do people seem to bloody love jojo
so much
how is this franchise seeped into modern
anime culture so deeply using his
arsenal of countless memes passionate
fans and weird poses to get where it is
today
especially considering it's over 25
years old now so
join me as i take a closer look at the
bizarre world of jojo's and its
popularity in my attempt to understand
holy [ __ ] guys he said stan was that a
[ __ ] jojo's reference
[ __ ] sake
now looking at the overwhelmingly
positive lights jojo's surrounded in and
the passion of his fandom you could
easily assume that couldn't this all
just be because
the series is really good which it is
nice
the passion and care put into the new
adaptation by david productions can
plainly be seen
and it's definitely deserving of the
positive reception it's gotten
critically i may joke about it but i
have a lot of positive things to say
about jojo's some of which i've been
saying
far before the new adaptation came to be
but its appeal is something that many
other people have already been able to
dissect so i won't be doing so here
simply put though it's a completely
unique and fascinating experience when
compared to your average show in action
series when someone's done watching the
four parts currently adapted and feel
like they need to watch something
similar there's nothing you can really
do beyond just consuming more jojo's and
other mediums and it's amazing to think
that a story plotted in the 80s still
feels fresher than most contemporary
anime and there has never been anything
quite like it
however viewing it through a critical
lens it has a good number of flaws which
is inevitable coming from a franchise
started in the 80s adapted to the modern
day but these are hardly ever mentioned
or even cared about in the general
consensus so i think there's more to it
than just the series being good a
positive critical reception doesn't
always equate to the love and passion
seen surrounding the jojo's franchise
and you only see something like this on
the rare occasion when the show comes
along that is both positively received
critically and immensely popular
so just how popular is jojo's really
well in japan it's no question really as
the franchise is one of the most
influential to come out of the world of
anime and manga the manga has been
steadily running for over 25 years to
this day
being one of the best selling manga of
all time and the amount of things that
have either been directly influenced or
referenced jojo's is ridiculous
from music gaming anime and other manga
there are so many jojo's references that
exist i'm pretty sure that we will
eventually reach a time that jojo's has
been running for so long it'll reach a
singularity where everything becomes a
jojo's reference
[Music]
but while his popularity and influence
in japan cannot be understated it hasn't
had the easiest time gaining traction
outside of that so from now on when i
refer to jojo's popularity i am talking
about it from a perspective
outside of japan and here in the west
jojo had an obscure cult following at
best for the longest time with only a
short
ova series subpar scandalations and
outer print volumes of part three alone
to draw people in it was a far cry from
the spread it has now it's only really
gained popularity since david's
production started giving it the long
overdue anime adaptation it thoroughly
deserved but considering how vocal the
fan base is and how often we see jojo's
memes and references floating around in
our community you'd think that jojo's
was close to mainstream success
but while trying to look for actual
numbers to back this up whether it be
its popularity or mao
view data on streaming sites or activity
and upvotes games on reddit i was hard
pressed
to find any concrete data to point at
jojo's being any more popular than the
standard hot anime to come out per
season
often being beaten out by a few shows in
it so why does it seem like the cultural
reach of this franchise goes much
further than any of these other shows
well to answer that let's look a bit
deeper at the culture of jojo's itself
especially since culture and history is
such an important part
in defining what jojo's is
[Music]
jojo's bizarre adventure is an epic saga
spanning generations but one of the
reasons it's been able to survive for as
long as it has is because
every part in jojo's is so unique and
diverse
for those unaware the story is separated
into parts with every part starring a
new member of the joe star lineage that
differs in
cast setting tone and sometimes genre
all brimming with their own pop culture
influences and references
global culture is deeply ingrained in
this franchise's roots and a big part of
what makes jojo feel unique
setting aside the countless music
references in the names of the
characters and stands let's take a look
at some of these influences
part one phantom blood started off in
19th century britain in the time of jack
the ripper with the heavy inclusion of
vampires being somewhat of a love letter
to bram stoker's dracula coming out
during the late
80s it was an era where stars like
stallone and arnie were everyday action
stars on the big screen which was a huge
inspiration to the bulky musty designs
that were a staple in these early days
along with the iconic fist of the north
star
the early franchise can almost be viewed
as a celebration of culture at the time
and this can truly be seen in part 2
battle tendency which switches us over
to america and it is here where the 80s
culture and the over-the-top bravado of
the action movies of the time get a
chance to truly shine
which it does combined with more global
influences world war
ii nazis and villains heavily influenced
by egyptian japanese and roman statues
of gods
all this leads to stardust crusaders
where iraqi fully embraces the global
influence
plotting a road trip star story inspired
by jules vernes around the world in 80
days
taking our crew to all sorts of exotic
places internationally and with this
flexibility of setting came the chance
for iraqi's external influences to truly
run wild his love for western horror was
made even more evident with characters
like enyabo and hanged man
and other villains reminiscent of the
premise seen on cult horror flicks like
nightmare on elm street and child's play
whole horse as the character was spawned
from his love of westerns and hell more
importantly jotaro was specifically
inspired by clint eastwood movies with
both his signature pose and even his
catchphrase being inspired by eastwood's
iconic images and attitudes in certain
films
go ahead make my day yeah
jojo's isn't just the inspiration for
much of anime pop culture in japan
it itself is seething with international
pop culture references and
influences to the bone every part adding
something new and evolving with real
world culture some acting almost like a
time capsule of culture at the time
these roots are part of why jojo's has
such a unique flavor its influence and
appeal doesn't just stem from japan but
it is global which combined with its
absolutely bizarre nature provides the
perfect ingredients to fuel a new
phenomenon that has hit our modern
culture
so you know what let's change gears a
bit let's
[ __ ] everything up and talk about
something stupid
let's talk about memes
let's be real here themes are stupid
memes are funny memes
are a massive part of our modern culture
shut up yes if you're a part of any
social media platform then you are
likely to see them every day
many people can consume news and world
events through the perception of memes
alone and though i'm not sure anyone can
properly define what a mean
is the best definition i've found is an
idea behavior or style that spreads from
person to person
within a culture which i'm not sure how
accurately can be used to describe every
way the term meme is being used now but
i think the important aspects to focus
on is the ability of mass replication
and how much power that holds
it's hilariously terrifying to think
that what started as some stupid macro
images has become an integral part of
modern culture as much as we like to
joke and laugh at them we shouldn't
dismiss the power of them
careers have been started and ended
overnight because of them amazing things
can be achieved with it and let's not
forget that many believe that this power
of simple
mass replication played a part in
electing a candidate into the highest
power of office in the world
akachi meme can spread awareness within
the community like wildfire and this is
no different for the anime community
think about how many of your own first
exposures to an anime have been through
a random gif or macro image on twitter
and facebook
now with this in mind what idea behavior
or style from the jojo's franchise can
we take
and easily spread within our culture
the jojo franchise is a full-on meme
making machine
stemming from its iconic characteristics
and just how unique it is
there is nothing even in anime quite
like jojo's and with every new parts
being so unique and fresh the well never
dries up
so much of jojo's doesn't make sense out
of context and oftentimes
in context leading to spreadable tidbits
that people can enjoy even if they have
no idea what the [ __ ] jojo's is about i
know more people who only know jojo's
through the memes and references than
have actually watched the show and a
huge part of its apparent popularity
comes from the amount of times you see a
jojo meme and people both jokingly and
non-jokingly referencing it all the god
damn time to say that jojo's works well
with modern meme culture is an
understatement the franchise was nion
built to thrive in it with its deep
roots in pop culture and its never
ending pool of spreadable
characteristics it has seized its way
into the consensus of modern anime
community which is amazing to think that
this all stems from a story written 20
odd years ago with its influence from
vintage western pop culture it itself
has become an integral part of modern
anime pop culture here in the west
which the more you think about there is
only one way we can properly describe
this phenomenon
bizarre we've gotten to a point where
the memes and this culture surrounding
jojo's may be more well known than
jojo's itself but while these stupid
memes gives the franchise to spread and
attention
what gives the franchise its power is
undoubtedly
the fan base
i don't think anyone will disagree with
me in saying that within this anime
community one of the most outspoken
and noticeable of them all lies within
the jojo's fandom though the critical
reception of the anime is partly
responsible for this i think a big
reason lies within his potential for fan
base investment and how the franchise
presents itself
why is it that multimedia titans like
star wars and marvel's have such a
dedicated and passionate fan base
it's because there is so much more to
them than just the movies or comics that
make up the law and appeal of a
franchise at large even looking at anime
be its gundam the face series even
something like pokemon to a lesser
extent if you get into the gundam
franchise for example you've got
hundreds of episodes of anime spread
across multiple timelines and that's
just the absolute flaw level
there's manga novels video games and not
forgetting the all-important model kits
you can spend years constantly consuming
the media and merchandise of franchises
like this and still end up with things
you've yet to come across
jojo's bizarre adventure has the
potential for huge fan base investment
in the way very few things do
each part has their own set of
characteristics and rules countless
stand users with interesting abilities
and a deep root in pop culture hell how
many jojo's fans out there have decided
to start listening to a band or song
entirely because there was a stand user
named after them how many people who
have gotten into the franchise for the
recent adaptations have gone on to read
all of the 20-plus
years worth of manga all this done under
the flagship of an anime series that is
obviously being handled with much
passion and love who are most likely
fans themselves there's so much of this
franchise to explore and latch onto but
with the way the franchise presents
itself there is no such thing as just
casually being a jojo's fan
part of being a jojo's fan is embracing
the over-the-top bravado that the series
relishes in
surrendering yourself to its
eccentricities to become a part of it
which is no doubt why the jojo's fandom
is one of the most passionate
outspoken and eccentric fandoms in anime
so much so that the idea of referencing
jojo at any given opportunity has become
a meme itself and to that end
passionately loving jojo's and
expressing that loudly has become a part
of this culture
at the end of the day there is no simple
way to describe this strange enigma that
is the jojo's franchise for a 25-plus
year-old franchise seemingly meshed so
perfectly with the spreadable meme
culture of today in itself is strange
but i think what's even more amazing is
that for as long as it has been running
there has never been anything quite like
it
it's a unique entity brimming with pop
culture global appeal and various other
influences while being able to stand on
its own without
any of that it's a highly entertaining
romp that stands up shouts to its
heart's content and refuses to be
ignored
and in doing so has created a fandom
cultivated out of passion and love
producing this culture around it that
seemingly has this bizarre mind of its
own
much like the show itself whatever it is
jojo's currently sits in a kind of weird
place
outside of its obvious influence and
popularity in japan it has become a
small cultural phenomenon for dedicated
fans here where the culture surrounding
the franchise may actually be better
known than the franchise itself
it's in this space just below mainstream
success but still instantly recognizable
for anyone who spent a decent amount of
time in the anime fandom and i think
because it's in the sweet spot that you
rarely see anything negative about it
it has enough critical backing a very
dedicated fan base a perfect platform
for its unique culture to spread but
just enough popularity that it doesn't
tip it over the breaking point which is
why this franchise is so loved and
seemingly can do nothing wrong
so the next time you see an out of
context jojo gif or millions of comments
referencing it or a group of people
doing weird ass poses
remember that weirdly enough that has
become part of what jojo's is about
and as much as i try to describe it
there is no way to fully comprehend it
unless you venture into the world
yourself
because you know what it's not just the
poses it's not just the memes the loud
fan base
the great ops the works of enemy stans
the beautiful dewangs the immortal young
iraqi the neverending manga the dio
zawado the references the pop culture
all the great
anime it's just jojo's if you enjoyed
this video
thank you very much this month to
thrones melt jared kettel
gabe brown onion by mario third season
and everyone else on patreon for helping
to support this channel and making this
video possible i'm actually back in the
uk briefly so i'll be attending mcm next
month if any of you are coming and now
maybe that i've made this video people
will stop commenting about jojo's in the
comments of my other videos
anyway that's it for me you can follow
me on twitter and facebook if you want
to know what i'm up to but until then
i'll see you all
next time